[Music]
foreign
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight on Facebook and uncensored Harry
and Megan reveal they've been invited to
the king's coronation but they won't say
if they'll deign to show up how much
more of this Sussex circus should any of
us have to tolerate
plus drugs cheat or victim of an
injustice I'll talk exclusively to boxer
Connor Ben on the dramatic fight to
clear his name out of failing drugs
tests
and after ransack enrolled dala nutrient
James Bond the dreaded sensitivity
readers are deployed to sanitize
ladybird Classics including Cinderella
and Snow White
[Music]
well good evening Rolanda welcome to
Piers Morgan uncensored I'm sick of
talking about them honestly I am I think
most of us are but they can't stop
yapping about themselves and putting
themselves into the news agenda so we
have to this is Harry and Megan who've
now regelled us with their truth so far
in sycophantic interviews with Oprah
Winfrey with James Gordon with Stephen
Colbert they've bashed Britain in six
hours of indulgent whining on Netflix so
front did Bob gas on their self-centered
versions of History Harry has barely
finished the global family trashing
tourism support of his treacherous
family trashing Memoir but never to be
he's decided that the world hasn't heard
quite enough from him
so Harry's latest wheeze is a live
therapy session with Dr Gable Marte have
fated to trauma expert in which he
reminded us again that he Harry is the
world's biggest victim
and then at some point you say towards
the end of the book
when is someone in this family going to
break free and live have you done that
I have now even
um there's a few like
it was great I do I I mean once the book
came out I felt I feel incredibly free I
fought a huge weight off my shoulders
oh shut up
fans paid 20
imagine paying for that the 90 minutes
of that psychobabble in which Harry
revealed you began therapy after a row
with Megan and again divulges his
fondness for drugs
I started doing it recreationally he
says and I started to realize how good
it was for me he's talking about
psychedelic narcotics I would say it's
one of the more fundamental parts of my
life that changed me and helped me deal
with the traumas and pains of the past
was that there's been an advert not
taking drugs it's old Harry isn't it U.S
border agents take a dim view of drug
use by non-us citizens Nigella lawsome
is once banned from flying to America
after admitting she'd take in cocaine
another compelling reason why we don't
want them at the king's coronation we
might end up being stuck with them for
good
well this unfortunately worded caption
of the story but time said it best at
the end of the talk with Prince Harry Dr
Gable Marte said he was suffering from
PTSD ADHD depression anxiety and panic
disorder no reports on what Harry's
suffering from after that so we're all
I think feeling the same way which is
enough
surely enough and yeah it won't be will
it it's going to keep going
and going and going
depicting themselves as the world's
greatest victims whilst pocketing
hundreds of millions of dollars
to describe their life victimhood
there's no end to the self-indulgent
arrogance from the sussexes and their
Grievances and they've now announced
that they've been in email
correspondence over their attendance at
the king's coronation but and I quote
exactly an immediate decision on whether
the Duke and Duchess will attend will
not be disclosed by us at this time
think about that response for a moment
that I could self-awareness is
jaw-dropping they've been invited to the
new monarch of Britain's coronation and
they'll go back to them with an answer
when they've thought about it
is there any wonder that their
popularity is plummeting on both sides
of Atlantic is it any wonder they become
objects of such Global ridicule Comedian
Chris rocks become a ladies comic to
Target Megan and Harry and his new
Netflix special
some of that she went through was not
racism
it was just some in-laws
sometimes it's just something
because she's complaining I'm like
talking about noper they're so racist
they wanted to know how Brown the baby
was gonna be that's not racist
because even black people want to know
Hal Brown the baby gonna be
well the subsequences have been on what
they call a journey when it comes to
their claims of racism in the Royal
Family First they're sensationally
accused the royal family directly of
racism then they tried to Gaslight us
into believing they never accused the
royal family of racism at all because
all the terrible media who've done that
now it's increasingly clear that just
about nobody takes any of these claims
seriously anymore Harry ended his
therapy session by addressing their
ruthless mockery in a recent episode of
South Park the more they criticized me
he said the more I need to share oh my
God
so same time tomorrow Harry if you keep
lying we'll keep having to cover it
well joining me now is author and
historian Tessa Dunlop who just flicked
something weird across the desk there in
her Fury at my monologue activist and
BLM organizer Iman ayton until to be
contributed to Esther Krakow and the
Sunday Times Royal editor Royal knicker
I want to start with because Roy you
broke the story that the king's office
has sent an emailed invitation to the
coronation for Harry and Megan but their
response to me said it all just the
arrogance of saying yeah we've got it
and we'll come back to you when we've
decided what we want to do
it was an interesting response um it
wasn't quite the response I suppose I
was expecting um I was just very keen
and asked and asked and asked whether or
not they had received an invite
um and got it very late on Saturday
night that they had in fact been invited
by The King and I suppose that's the
olive branch that everyone has been
waiting for there has been so much
speculation about whether or not they
were going to be invited and then come
but of course now everyone is going to
be waiting to see if they both come if
just Harry comes of course it's Archie's
fourth birthday on the day so there is
there is that to take into account um
but yeah we now wait and see when they
might RSVP to the king I mean like you
say an Olive Branch from the king and a
big one frankly because you know he's
just had to put up with all this
trashing in the book about him about his
wife Camilla about his son William about
gay all of them got it in this book so
he made the olive branch which is seen
as the decent thing for him to do
although I wouldn't recommend that he do
it if they if they come we're going to
have the circus the entire time they're
over and it will in some way overshadow
the coronation not completely but it
will certainly cast a shadow if they
don't come my view is well all right
we'll have a bit of noise about them not
coming but there won't be that shadow
they'll be in California nowhere near
the action when it happens isn't the
smart play for everybody that they just
stay in Montecito
the thing is I think the king wouldn't
have issued that invite unless he
actually really really wanted his son
there um he wants his son there I think
the other thing we saw with the Platinum
Jubilee service last year for her
majesty the Queen the late queen of
course is that they did come over and
they were actually able after all the
hullabaloo of earlier last year after
Oprah and all of that they were able to
actually come to parts of it and stay
out of the Limelight I think the other
thing to remember here is a coronation
is a once in a generation massive deal
there will be golden carriages there
will be 2 000 people in The Abbey it
will be an extraordinary site Harry and
Megan yes okay there's a bit of a circus
around them but I think all eyes will be
on the king and queen and everything
else that's going on that day and the
rest of the royal family so I think it's
doable I don't think that if they come I
don't think they're going to completely
steal the show they didn't last year for
the Platinum Jubilee it can be done well
I hope you're right uh Roya but another
cracking scoop congratulations in the
Sunday Times appreciate you joining me
thank you very much uh okay let's get
into this Iman
the Chris Rock thing first of all did
make me laugh out loud because of course
I was accused of being a racist for not
believing all this racism garbage that
she was coming out with now Chris Rock
has said it is he a racist okay well we
have to put everything they said into
context first okay so he said that
everyone wants to pay the victim and he
also referred to white men being the
most recent culprits alongside Meghan
Markle he also said that uh Megan had uh
won the light-skinned lotteries and the
words she has light skin privilege and
so therefore he couldn't quite
understand why she was still complaining
he also said that she was acting dumb in
regards to the royal family and that's
when he proceeded to say that they were
the original racist they invented
colonialism and they were the ogs of
racism so in other words racism should
be expected so he basically spent the
best part of his set making it that
clear that the royal family were a bunch
of racists and that Megan markle's
ignorance well he was eluding basically
Ludacris he was alluding to colonialism
and you can certainly frame an argument
that there was obviously racism and
colonism I can accept that well we're
talking about the current members of the
royal family being directly accused of
racism Esther and what really annoyed me
about Harry retracting that was that two
years of damaging allegations left to
hang around the world that the Royals
have been racist and then he turns
around and said well you're never meant
to be right well then I always made the
point that he didn't know what he was
talking about because he he started
trying to wade into a conversation that
was way out of his debt saying he was
unconscious bias and I often made the
point that hold on you've let these
allegations stew for two years saying
that there was concern about the
darkness of your child even people that
are not particularly fond of anything to
do with racial politics would say that
is racist right but then you need to
turn around and say actually the media
said that it was racist and that we we
are suddenly so so so blind and all we
do is follow the media that we can't
actually discern this for ourselves
that's when everyone on both sides of
the debate said you don't know what
you're talking about you know what says
yeah look I mean we've talked about this
a lot I feel like Prince Harry here like
the white plonker do you know what yeah
when I when I left Good Morning Britain
I think I've thought about this before
when I left Good Morning Britain is
because specifically I didn't believe
Meghan markle's claims that she'd gone
to someone at the palace and said she
was suicidal and they said she couldn't
get any treatment or therapy or help and
also I didn't believe the racism claims
now what's interesting is neither of
those no but hang on Tessa here's my
point neither of those claims get
repeated in Harry's 420 page book it's
like they never happened and yet they
were the incredibly incendiary and
explosive allegations which triggered
this whole thing
what happened to them where did they go
it's a question of nuance I am very
clearly a white woman but I am married
to a foreigner at the bottom of the
European pecking order a Romanian and I
remember and my my a wider family deny
this I remember my aunt her little pink
fist banging on the table our country is
too full we don't want him over here I
remember the way they spoke to him such
as some members not all members with a
louder voice like he was a tradesperson
coming in the back door in the 1950s
this stuff it filters in it's very hard
to prove it's hard to articulate and
we're talking about white on white and
the in the context
right okay I know I've I I've I've
explained something about that but I'm
talking about anything but it's very
hard to ask they're hard to prove and
they're actually
um what happens is they get labeled they
get pigeonholed they get pushed inside
I'm sorry sorry actually I believe Harry
when he said he felt something I've hung
around public school boys I've been in a
group that's fine just referred to that
Sabrina and Venus Williams
we're not talking about any of those
things listen here's my point fine we
are actually aren't we well no that's
what I'm talking about they went on
global television to Oprah Winfrey the
most famous people in the world yeah and
they made direct allegations of racism
that they now have said they simply
didn't make we didn't mean to say
enormous racist they've never named
anybody who they originally said said
these things nothing it doesn't appear
in the book it's just vanished after two
years of incredible damage to the brand
of the monarchy and I just say the
agenda's changed I just want to just
throw that point in I've said this
several times there are generous change
Pairs and so therefore their tactics
have tuned so that is why it's no longer
in the book because I promise right now
is about getting them on should they
have the goal to turn up at the
coronation bear in mind these two have
done so much to damage the institution
of the monarchy in the last three years
why would they even want to be there
celebrating the coronation of our next
king well firstly I think it is more
than possible to highlight racism with
an institution whilst simultaneously
wanting to reconnect with your family
that's the first point secondly is that
what they did did they highlight racism
that was the original plan to highlight
races and we already know that they have
back pedals with that yeah so there was
no race we already know that and in
terms of the combination well it's
Archie's birthday as we already know so
for me personally yeah four-year-old
kids birthday party versus coronation
I don't believe that don't be a favor do
not call me skeptical why don't you
think they banned the coronations
insanity of course they didn't plan the
coronation to ruin a four-year-old kid's
birthday party
I think I I think it could have been a
winner
Esther apparently they've done this
deliberately correlation it's a really
Nazi's birthday I do see that argument
there could be Merit there because if
they say they're not coming because of
Archie's birthday
what we've got is to me they're like
teenagers and teenagers often make
really good points they're at the front
of pushing the envelope forward they've
made their case sometimes in articulate
sometimes clumsy sometimes egregiously
okay now they're in their bedroom right
and we need them to come out the bed no
we don't yes they need to climb down
because Mommy and Daddy at the table
want them absolutely yes if you do the
metaphor and by the way here's the other
point we do it's not just about what the
king wants because it's his son it's
about what the king should do is the
right thing for the country that's what
I wanted the king represents all of us
right I don't think the most people in
Britain want Aaron Megan anywhere near
the Commonwealth can I just say I don't
think that this is in terms of the crime
Nation I don't think this is simply just
about whether King Charles wants them
there or whether Harry and Megan want to
be there I actually think that this is
due to reputation management and I think
it comes down to what is best for the
institution and I believe what is best
is uh all right do you think they should
be there Redemption yes or no I think
that can Charles should prioritize they
should be there issues within his family
so they think they should go I don't
think they should go I think it's it's
this is something for the British public
I'm I'm quite frankly I'm sick of The
Saga I'm sick of the drama I'm sorry for
the issues that they're having but this
should be happening behind closed so if
they do come they do come here's what
they're going to do they're going to
bring a camera crew they're going to
bring recorders and they're going to
invade the privacy of the royal family
all over here's and here's what's going
to be the winners the royal family will
win if they come they will win if they
come and you the press the populist
press will win Pierce so it's all gone
to get them on those pews I shall no
longer the popular press I'm a
television presenter of a show called
interesting yeah uh well look I'm glad
we all reach an agreement that I'm right
[Music]
interview is next
foreign
[Music]
two drug tests this is a nightmare for
me I was hoping most nights my faith let
me down you were feeling suicide I
didn't think I'd see another day
there are millions and millions of
pounds at stake here you have a Welter
of information but it still won't
clearly why don't you put it on the
internet appears you know it ain't as
simple as that
I've been proven in this no I wouldn't
say you've been proven innocent I am
innocent you know if I had done
something wrong I'll raise my hands to
it I made a mistake whatever it is I
don't know
[Music]
foreign
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Feltz on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
welcome back to Piers organization
Connor Ben the son of boxing Legend
Nigel Ben was one of British boxing's
biggest prospects but in October last
year just days away from a domestic
Grudge super match with Chris Eubank Jr
Ben was accused of failing Two drugs
tests and the fight was postponed he's
chosen to speak to me exclusively on the
dramatic fight he now has to clear his
name
Connor Thank you for joining me why are
you doing this interview oh because I
feel like a lot of people have
speculated no time to say what they want
to say and um I've never never been able
to speak on it
the call of public opinion has been
pretty Savage about what's happened I
think it's because when the public hear
anything about drugs in sport or
cheating or anything like that they
immediately assume the worst and and
most of the time they're right to assume
that let's be honest about it
you're in that horrible position for any
Sportsman where you failed two drug
tests and you're trying to prove your
innocence
but you've probably seen what social
media has been saying how has that
impacted on you I mean it's been brutal
um you know it does feel like a Witch
Hunt I've never seen anything quite like
this before in any other athlete whether
they've raised their hands to it or you
know they've just taken a small ban you
know I was willing to fight for my
innocence and improve my innocence what
I did was an easy way out in the
beginning in lying and saying oh I may
have accidentally done this I may have
done this by accident and taken a small
six-month ban instead I've chose to
fight this because my Integrity mad more
to me and I would never ever ever raise
my hands to something I ain't done four
months ago you're preparing for one of
the biggest fights of your life against
Chris Eubank Jr
everyone was waiting for this huge
anticipation we all remembered what
happened when the two fathers fought I
remember it very well know your dad well
and Chris Eubank senior
um and then your World falls apart
what is that moment like for you when
you heard about the failed drug test
um I didn't think anything of it to be
fair when it was the first one
um when they said they found an adverse
fund and I didn't really think anything
of it really no not at all isn't that
every Sports was Nightmare um no because
I thought there may have been an era I
thought let's run another test straight
away Let's do let's you know that I know
I never even heard of this thing before
this is the first time a drug which is
uh clomiphene which can boost
testosterone levels but I'm 26. I'm
trying to reduce body fat yeah I'm just
saying what it is yes I'm 26 when people
are saying no I may have needed a
testosterone booster I'm 26 years old
yeah I didn't even know what his thing
was at a time so for me I thought okay
you know it may have been you know an
error or an accident somewhere
um along we can find out what's happened
and then when it was when I found out
that you know they've been a second
adverse finding was when I was like okay
now something's actually wrong there's
something wrong here and um what are you
feeling inside yourself at that point
who's done this to me
I generally looked around and I thought
it was the hardest part of this whole
period of everything I've been through
this was the hard part was because I was
looking around and thinking okay
I'm actively taking it
it's actively in something or is
Something's Happened it's definitely
there and these were the thoughts that
were going on through my head who's done
this do you accept this was in your body
I don't accept who's in my body not at
all based on
independent scientists looking at the
reports based on my own scientists
looking at the reports and and what we
found people say you may have paid for
the best legal team
damn right I pay for the best legality
damn right I pay for the best scientists
my career is on the line my image is on
the line my name is on the line and I
can't be known for this and it was a
more so me employing the best people to
find out what had actually happened what
do you think of people who cheat in
sport it should be bad for life
especially in contact yeah bam for life
you know it's there's no room for it
there's been a fire today who's who's
just had a brain hemorrhage there's no
room for it I know firsthand the damage
it does from my dad with other with Joe
McLennan I was there one side of that
fight I mean both men got saved in the
hospital both nearly died and you think
I do it and people think I'd do this
it's hard for me because it's like I
turned problem 19 a month with the
public eye and I've seen how hard I work
over the years they've seen you know the
three three in the morning runs they've
seen the nutrition they've seen the
workout appointment with my coaches you
know everyone can vouch for how hard I
work but
that's not good enough normally I would
say the vast majority of times a
sportsman test positive for drugs they
always say I didn't do it invariably and
then almost always it is proven that
they did you're in a strange position
of you're in a kind of mid mid position
right now because the WBC
have come back and they have said uh
that they think there may have been
reasons why you had this in your body
but they have made a presumption it was
in your body you don't even accept that
I don't accept that how when they say
you may have taken and he got a lot of
attention this and to mockery yeah but
when they said it may have been a highly
elevated consumption of eggs could have
created this positive testing you you
don't even accept that I don't accept
that no the WBC while I was on the me
and my team won a phone to them
um on a zoom call they had come out and
said that they are one of their
scientists are currently dealing with
two cyclists who have tested positive
for clomorphine in traces and they can
prove this in the embryos and the eggs
I'm not willing to accept it because the
270 page report that I sent over to them
what my team sent over to them had
nothing to do with eggs it had
everything to do with my test testing
negative three times and nine days later
testing positive they didn't conclude
they found anything wrong with the
testing
what they did say they said there was no
conclusive evidence that must have been
engaged in intentional or knowing
ingestion of clomathy I don't believe it
was there in the first place you gotta
remember I've never I don't even know
what this thing is coincidentally for my
first Vader test coincidentally for the
biggest fight of my career there's a
there's a substance in my body that I
haven't even heard of the reality is
this particular drug which is becoming
more prevalent in sport and no one's
quite sure why but it can as I said
boost testosterone levels by 50 it can
reduce body fat so it clearly would have
tangible benefits on an athlete I mean
it would whoever the athlete is it would
help
if someone was doing it deliberately it
would help well definitely but what a
WBC is saying is even a the peak of it
in my system is still only a trace why
don't you give this dossier 270 pages of
it why don't you give it to the British
boxing Board of control because they're
ultimately the ones that can sanction or
not sanction your right to fight in this
country my dad tore up his British
boxing license until in the 80s you know
the board don't ain't going to stop me
from fighting they can't stop me from
fighting look it's not having a
professional fight in this country in
this country and that's fine so be it is
they filed they filed seven misconduct
charges against me one of them was they
wanted because we wanted the fight to go
ahead the second one was because we
didn't tell Eubank immediately and on
the Monday they said we're upholding all
charges I thought you look and do one
you think I'm gonna sit here and take
this what they've said is will show us
the evidence but I couldn't get you've
got you've got 270 pages of apparent
evidence surely the smart thing to do
whatever your views of the of the board
control they are the governing body
surely you should just give them your
evidence let them respond that's that's
down to my legal team you know they've
always stop you I don't understand what
stops you my pride the way they've dealt
with this the way they won't get you
through this but I don't have to be
licensed by the board That's My Views
you do the fight in Britain I don't plan
on finding brain anytime soon just put
it all on the internet I want to trust
me what's stopping you the ongoing legal
cases that's that's the only that's
something this is your career your
livelihood this is everything at stake
here
isn't it I agree everything's on the
light I agree and this is what I keep
trying to tell my life but you can't do
this you can't do that mate this would
have been public I've known what I've
known since December and I've kept quiet
everyone firing everyone attacking me
everyone and I've known what I've known
since December and I'm sitting here
again going well why can't we just
release the information why can't the
public just know what's actually gone on
so the public you know from what I just
I looked at it today social media is
Savage
they've convicted you they think you're
guilty and I'm gonna have to deal with
that I think I think publicity how are
you going to deal with that there will
be there any hernia promoter says look
it's time to you've got to move on to
progress what do you think when when he
says that well I don't think they're I
think the public have made up their mind
already irrelevant of what's presented
relevant of what the boards say I've got
strong DNA and I'm one hell of a fire
naturally I work harder I've made loads
of sacrifices and I'm willing to do what
other people aren't willing to do and
that's why I'm where I am not because
they're cheating if you feel this
passionately about it
I can sense it I can sense you're
emotional about this
to be branded achieved in the court of
public opinion what what has that done
to you
um yes it's um
it's um yeah it's hurt me yeah it's um
it's been
um yeah it's her media says
how badly um
I didn't think I was going to make it
through this period I didn't think um
through
um you know it was a shame for saying I
ain't even done you know it's hard
because it was like I felt like I was on
different for something I ain't even
done you know if I had done something
wrong you know I'm human you know I'll
raise my hands to it I made a mistake
whatever it is my personal life whereas
I raise my hands never
never this and you know I felt like
seven years of hard work and sacrifice
and leaving my family and and the image
I maintained was just you know ruined at
somebody else's incompetence you know it
was um yeah it's um it's been hard for
them that you make it what do you mean
um
I don't think I would um I didn't think
I'd I was taking day by day I didn't
think I'd see another day you were
feeling suicidal yeah I'd say so yeah
yeah now upsets me now because
because I I don't know how I got so bad
I got in a really bad way but you got my
brother you gotta remember if if you
think I'm innocent or if you don't think
I'm innocent
I am innocent yeah I mean look let me be
clear I don't know right this is the
first time we've met I know your father
from old I've watched you from afar the
minds you're working a boxing ring I
don't know if you're honest I would
never do this to my family I would never
do this to my supporters you think I'd
do this to my dad
to my son who's now gotta grow up and
and look her
well look at this
you think I it's not who I am
cheat or victim we're coming up more
Revelations from Connor Ben and his
boxing Ledger father Nigel also joins us
for a bold intervention
[Music]
foreign two drug tests this is a
nightmare for me I was hoping most
nights my faith let me down you were
feeling suicide I didn't think I'd see
another day
there are millions and millions of
pounds at stake here you have a Welter
of information but it still won't
clearly why don't you put it on the
internet because you know it ain't as
simple as that
I've been proven in this no I wouldn't
say you've been proven innocent I am
innocent you know if I had done
something wrong I'll raise my hands to
it I made a mistake whatever it is I
don't know
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
thank you
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Felts is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talktv every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
this is talk TV
[Music]
welcome back now to the final part of
Masters of interview with Connor Ben
he's just revealed that he was just
feeling suicidal up to failing Two drugs
tests which made him a target a Savage
online abuse so I asked him about that
abuse and just how bad it got
there's been there's been too many
you know what kind of thing
um just kill yourself
people have told you to kill you kill
yourself people said um yeah kill
yourself racist comments to my son with
my family on social media yeah
yeah anything in in person in the street
person no never nothing in person
um you know it's cowardly he's cowardly
I think I I don't even think it's social
media that bothers me it's it was more
so the shame I felt leaving the house
although I had done nothing wrong I you
know I was having night terrors panic
attacks you know
and I don't throw I don't throw these
words out in mental health I was really
struggling I was in a really bad way um
you know and I was coping terribly with
it
um you know I was coping in a really bad
way how do you know about it
um
it's still hard for me because it's
because I still can't believe I'm in a
situation
you know I still can't believe how much
the public want me to be guilty they saw
boxing pundits you're telling me I'm
guilty boxing plan this telling me I'm
guilty they know me they know my family
you know what I Stand For You Know Who I
Am why are you trying why are you trying
to label me a cheat you're not suing the
labs right
well there there is that talk you think
I what manufacturing manipulating and
concealing evidence that I got an
independent scientist lyrical report and
that's what we've seen from one of the
best manipulation manufacturing but that
wasn't verified by the WBC was the WBC
going to come out and say well that's
what I mean you've got to go to the
governing body that can actually go out
with this properly do well it's hard
because I want this to be done I want
this to be finished and I want to resume
with my career should I just sit back
and accept the fact that you're going to
sue the board no of course I'll be soon
the board went up
when it will be showing them now my
legal scene will be in touch with you
mean when you know as soon as so much
money do you know for the full loss of
earnings damaged reputation what how
much is it because I don't the board
don't the board should have recognized
Vita let me ask
let me ask him for a moment your theory
is right it's a theory it's not proven
scientifically yet and hasn't been
ratified by any governing body but if
your theory is right it was contaminated
it would prompt the question well why
who would want to do that it would be in
the only way it would be contamination
if it is whose interest is it to to ruin
this great fight absolutely I'm not
saying it was deliberate what in the lab
I'm not saying it was the liberal you
know it may be an error in the testing
I'm not saying deliberately I'm not
saying that anyone's in their Labs
deliberately done this it may I'm not
saying that at all but it may be an
accident it may be an error there are
millions and millions of pounds at stake
here dollars whatever you say is this
does this all sound from what I've said
about the testing manipulation
manufacturing Casino evidence from what
I'm saying to you does that sound does
that sound listen you sound like you
have a Welter of information but I
cannot for the life of me understand why
you wouldn't then give it to the the
governing body it's down to them whether
you fight in this country again yeah so
I don't understand that that to me makes
sense I can their license elsewhere what
does any I mean a lot of time pretty
earn he's a I think he's a brilliant
promotion he cares about his Fighters he
wants you to try and move on from this
that's that's his advice right what have
you said to him about that
I just said I need the biggest fight
possible the hardest fight soda when I
beat that person in devastating fashion
there's no questions as to my whole
career there's no questions it's done
that's that's what that's what I want to
do I can't come back I don't need no
warm-up I Don't Need No Easy fight I
don't need a Walmart to get back into it
I'm 26 years old
give me the best name give me the bean
training problem of course I have I've
tried throughout this whole period is it
hard to train properly when you're on
this now it's fine mental state now it's
fine I I struggled there was probably
about two months where I was um yeah I
was in a really bad way you know did you
talk to your dad about it
um I did but my dad was in a bad way as
well
why over this over this yeah yeah
I was I was in about sobbing most nights
I was didn't want to go to sleep because
if I knew what I had to wake up to
um
you got me and this is a nightmare for
me
how has this happened how have I how
have I got in this situation my faith
let me down you feel that oh yeah 100
yeah let me bring in your dad who's been
listening to this he's over in Sydney
Nigel I've not talked to you for a long
time we used to have uh a few years
together it's good to see you um I've
got three sons all in their 20s actually
one of whom is is Connor's age and I
can't imagine many tougher things for a
father to have to deal with than
listening to your son talking in such a
profoundly emotional and upsetting way
about feeling suicidal in the last few
weeks and months since all this went
down
how does that first of all make you feel
as a father to hear this
um
Pierce I was actually in the same same
position as my son
um I was really struggling as well for
myself
I don't really drink
um every night I was drinking like half
a bottle of ring Wayne a night on on
medication
and um yeah we both we both were in the
dark dark dark place because then
to me
it looks like this is a Witch Hunt it's
like we're going back to 1800s she's a
witchy the witchy the witch burner
burner yeah hold on a minute that's my
son
the one thing here if I ever thought my
son was guilty or anything mate I'd say
son I love you but you know what you
gotta deal with this on your own mind
I'd hang him out to dry but I was
actually in this training camp within
peers I was training with him I would
say on that that there are lots of
benefits to being the son of somebody
famous I've had this conversation with
my sons but there are also disadvantages
Connor will get an irrational amount of
attention because he's your son I don't
understand why there's this compelling
dossier of 270 pages of material why not
make that public and why not give it to
the British boxing board
okay listen I agree with you pierce but
the same way I feel that they're David
McConnor in not even the fires is that
uh the same way they dealt with me
listen Nigel I understand your passion I
understand Connor's passion but I also
think if you've gone to all this trouble
to draw up this massive dossier of
evidence and the British boxing board is
asking for it I don't understand how it
can be anything but bad for your case if
you don't hand it over I mean at very
least call their Bluff say right here
you are get them to respond to it I
don't know why if I was in your position
that's what I would do you're like your
father you are your own man right you
are and if you wanted to you could put
this out there tonight
yeah I still don't think that proves
minor sense at all I've just been
cleared by the organization which the
testing which I felt I don't understand
why you wouldn't want to counter that
agenda by making public this dossier
because I don't know what it is they got
him for me I don't know what I don't
know what what Vendetta is yeah but it's
like saying you're accused of killing
someone okay but I've been proven in
this authorities that run that test I
wouldn't say you've been proven innocent
they just couldn't just give me the
clear they've said they said there's no
conclusive evidence just to be clear
exactly what they said right it's not an
absolutely unequivocal you're definitely
Innocent but it's certainly not
unhelpful I've seen Sportsman come back
from this when they've gone through the
process
yeah I I do agree with you
um I don't know what the legal side of
it but yeah I I me personally and I love
my son you know and I know for a fact
innocent man Nigel as a again as
speaking as a father now
you know Connor taught very movingly
about you know sobbing every night while
talking to you you're in Australia the
other part of the world you know the
time zones you're drinking you're
feeling terrible too those conversations
must be some of the most painful you've
ever had in your life right what did you
say to Connor in those in those
conversations to try and stop him from
as he put it you know considering taking
his life
uh I'll be honest with you because it
was like
I come I'm here because I was with
Connor for five months
I was in I wasn't here I was in England
moving so while he was going through
this period like I I was there within my
state I'd say until January uh and then
after then my mum died so I had so much
pressure on me
and I was just a mess and and so I was
an actually really good talk on it
because actually I was trying to be
strong but there again it was like a
wiley without I you know he was dealing
with his own and she's not going to try
to deal with mine and and we struggled
and we struggled we we both got through
to go thank God Nigel I've got a I've
got to wrap wrap it unfortunately what I
would say to you Connor is I I feel that
you're in a lot of pain about this
that's clear and I'm extremely sorry
you've been going through what you've
been going through because nobody should
ever feel that way and it's it's awful
and the court of public opinion on
social media could be particularly
brutal experience myself it's a very
very unpleasant thing
but I also think you can turn that round
But ultimately this may be down to you
deciding what you want to do with your
life and your future and your career I
mean what is the dream for you out of
this hell just about fighting the fines
the easy part the fine this has been the
hardest five I've ever had to face
I find is the easy part that's that's
not born fine it's in my blood
well Connor I wish you well in in
pursuing this I'm not going to make a
judgment until it's all concluded you
know the facts are what they are as we
know them but the facts can develop you
know if there is genuinely new
information which exonerates you my
advice is get it out there thank you so
thank you very much and Nigel I
appreciate you joining me from Australia
it's very early over there and I thank
you also for your calendar thank you
very much
thank you and tell Connor to get that
thing off his top lick
well that is a problem I agree yeah some
things fathers can't just get something
to do all my sons have weird facial hair
it's got to stop I agree hey good to
talk to you now just been been a while
and I appreciate you joining me
well next tonight lock up your Disney
Princesses the so-called dredge
sensitivity readers
they're coming for them we'll discuss
that after the break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
two drug tests this is a nightmare for
me I was hoping most nights my faith let
me down you were feeling suicide I
didn't think I'd see another day
there are millions and millions of
pounds at stake here you have a Welter
of information but it still won't clear
exactly why don't you put it on the
internet because you know it ain't as
simple as that
I've been proven in this no I wouldn't
say you've been proven innocent I am
innocent you know if I had done
something wrong I'll raise my hands to
it I made a mistake whatever it is I
don't know
[Music]
thank you
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on
talk TV
[Music]
passionate and always straight to the
point world-class broadcaster Vanessa
Feltz is on talk TV every night of the
week
from politics to pop culture there's no
subject she shies away from
and remember if you're thinking about it
we're talking about it join Vanessa
Felts on talk TV every day from 4pm
[Music]
thank you
well welcome back join me I'll talk to
you contributor Esther cracker
Associates at the Battalion mirror Kevin
McGuire so
some extraordinary interview with Connor
been there because I don't know whether
you tell me the truth or not how can I
know yeah only he really knows he's
failed these two drug tests and he's
pleading with us to think he's not that
kind of guy the problem I have with
these sort of interviews Kevin is that I
mean pretty much every sporting cheat
that's the kind of thing they say when
they get caught yeah Lance Armstrong uh
Ben Johnson Back in the Day Shane Warne
actually who did rebuild his his career
see all right I think he failed one
failed two sorry uh is becoming a
coincidence here but if you have
evidence you've got to publish that
evidence well that's the bit I don't get
it it's like he kept telling me I've got
all the evidence I've got this dossier
so we'll give it to the yeah exactly
give it to the governing body because or
at the very least publish it let the
media see it right and then they can
decide I mean he's reacting very
emotionally clearly because obviously
this is his career on hold it at the
peak of his career at 26 and I
understand that but you know there was a
lot of kind of blaming not himself yeah
and I just think you are you are very
talented very elite Sportsman you are
you are surrounded by an elite team you
could say that oh someone gave me a pill
and I didn't know what it was and they
were qualified so I just took it but at
the end of the day I'm assuming that
might be in the dossier or if he has
evidence what is bizarre is the world
boxing Council the WBC they issued this
report saying that they can't prove that
he deliberately ingested this thing but
they did say they believed it was in his
body he doesn't even accept that they
even gave him a get out they said look
it could be he took too many eggs he got
this got ridiculed but there was a WBC
offering him a kind of Alibi for why
this might be in his body which he is
just completely rejected now either that
is the response of a lunatic in other
words you're being given to get out here
or it's a response to somebody who
genuinely believes he's been aggrieved
it yeah or or he's been badly advised
yeah maybe maybe that's the third option
don't know because they were bending
over backwards to be fair yeah they were
and he thinks he's the victim of a
conspiracy theory theory he thinks
someone is conspiring against him at the
peak of his career and I'm like okay
fine but you have the evidence that
you're clean I don't think he's got any
chance of clearing his name and as he
hands that dossier today and and
publishes it simultaneously it's all I
would do it's Chris Eubank Jr I really
feel sorry for yeah yeah
fight and take place yeah I agree
um let's turn to uh well first of all
sensitivity readers
raising their ugly heads once I don't
know who these people are but you just
know they're ugly right first they came
for Roald Dahl then they came to James
Bond now they're coming for fairy tales
which apparently are too offensive and
need to be changed
well ladybird books are said to be
examining Tales like Cinderella and Snow
White
so Cinderella won't be assuming the
prince uses he or him pronouns it could
be non-binary
handsome prince and beautiful princess
well they're out too because that could
make young readers think that all that
matters in life is being attractive God
forbid and don't you dare have old ugly
villains because that's ageist
uh so you can't be beautiful you can't
be ugly you can't be a villain you can't
you know already be fat you can only be
enormous this is all ridiculous isn't it
I mean I I am deeply offended because
this is Disney and I love Cinderella and
Sleeping Beauty and all of these stories
growing up I just think what is the
point why are you rewriting an author's
Vision because it goes far you can
disagree with the ideology You can
disagree with calling a princess
beautiful who is offended by this but
you don't get to rewrite it who's
affected who are these people who are
these absolute cretins out there but who
think you know what the thing about
Cinderella is it's offenses look shut up
look go away go back under the cruel you
came out of the sensitivity readers they
said oh be banned fired sent away ah
hang on hang on you wouldn't say Agatha
Christie's and then they were non would
go back to its old title of ten little
and then use the N word so you so you
accept the principle there is a lot fine
that is cross okay I'll accept right
I'll accept that there isn't there is a
lot because I don't think you should be
completely everything should be
published the way it used to be if for
example it has the N word and a title I
get that right although some people
don't but some people think you should
just stick yeah rigidly but I can accept
there might be very very few exceptions
but when you start getting into whether
a prince might be non-binary this is
complete nonsense
even even even me and I kind of think
books should by and large stand as they
were written yeah but I read books to my
grandkids and they're bought by their
parents or my daughter and her husband
and they're very different to the books
we read to our kids that I read to my
daughter and I can see perhaps people
aren't buying them anymore perhaps if
you're Lady Bird you've got repealed to
a new market so it's a commercial
pressure because this Market is a tiny
Market of people people honestly who do
you meet in real world who thinks this
way I didn't meet these people I mean I
think I think to be honest there is a
party try I go I go out in the street
are you awoke imbecile where are you
are you feeling oversensitive today
there's a ladybird book upset you I
think they're trolling us I think the
point where they talk about the the
prince being non-binary I think they're
true to an extent ridiculous we're
talking Charlie guys
um Hancock okay so in the telegraph
lockdown files which are endlessly sort
of riveting and entertaining and equal
measure and horrifying of course
um he emerges exactly how I thought he
was which is basically all about Matt
Hancock yeah and we actually we saw one
message today in the in the coverage
where he's talking about the vaccine
rollout desire for a turbo boost for it
I called for this two months ago he
messages on WhatsApp to his team this is
a Hancock Triumph
you're talking about himself that's it
I mean what is he doing here I mean
these theories that Alex Sharma might go
on TV which given her appalling Alex was
a TV I don't blame him pretty I'm not in
the Commons I should do a clip I should
definitely do the rounds tomorrow it
must not be a lot because alot might get
some credit it's pathetic I mean he is
he has no self-awareness I think that I
mean we're able to establish that but
this is just shows the extent of his
narcissism because he actually felt like
he was a victim of you know a privacy
breach because he was caught
heavy petting a lady who was cheating on
his wife with and then he got these
messages were released and he he thinks
he's part of a conspiracy to to you know
breach his privacy and now he he
believes that he should get credit for
everything he's some sort of well the
one thing Kevin which emerges from this
is a conclusion is nothing constitutes a
Hancock Triumph no no no no and he's the
man who put the into her okay
and I think I think he just shows
himself to be thin-skinned incompetent
chaotic and attention seeking because he
wants attention but his triumphs yeah
when they don't exist and none of that
would have really mattered if he hadn't
been in health secretary at the time of
Covenant people weren't dying in large
numbers yeah in Care Homes and elsewhere
words Hancock Triumph are not being used
no he's protective ring was not a
protective ring at all uh guys go over
there thank you very much indeed uh
enjoyed seeing you that's it from me
whatever you're up to Keep It Uncensored
good night
thank you
[Music]
the failed two drug tests this is a
nightmare for me I was hoping most
nights my faith let me down you were
feeling suicide I didn't think I'd see
another day
there are millions and millions of
pounds at stake here you have a Welter
of information but it still won't clear
why don't you put it on the internet
because you know it ain't as simple as
that
I wouldn't say you've been proven
innocent I am innocent you know if I had
done something wrong I raised my hands
to it I made a mistake whatever it is I
don't know
[Music]
he's back and he's uncensored
debating the breaking news and talking
to the biggest names Piers Morgan is
live every week with a host of stars
uncompromising
unmissable
and uncensored
and remember if you're thinking it
we're talking about it Piers Morgan
uncensored Monday to Thursday at 8pm on